bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv en
direct de saint quentin 50 en 2015
championnat de france première ronde et
on va voir aujourd'hui une très jolie
partie jouée par une des grandes
joueuses françaises du nahd du national
féminin natacha benmesbah bonjour ma
tâche a alors premier rang et puis tu
voulais contre une adversaire assez
forte à cydia colas membre de l'équipe
de france oui tu la connais quand vous
tenez je vous dis mais on a joué à
quelques fois qu'une très bonne joueuse
très solide
elle joue très bien et je traîne donc
c'était un peu un peu stressant oui un
peu stressant c'est une foire de faisans
suisse était la première ronde du
tournoi faut commencer sur de bonnes
bases
ouais j'ai les blancs ceci dit le
national toutes les rondes tout terrain
sont importantes mais si on commence
bien c'est qu'ils encouragent ans que
pour la suite voilà on va voir donc
cette première partie encourageante
donc tu as les blancs oui j'ai les bras
face à un sida colas donc tu démarres
par le coût du roi oui donc c'est ton
âme d'ouverture aux favoris de services
et ce que je veux dire quasi
exclusivement c'est bobby fischer ton
modèle où c'est plutôt visite paul
guérin mais fish a oui j'ai bien aimé
alors donc s'il y ajouter sa c5 donc une
sicilienne
alors les joueurs connaissent un taux ce
début donc cavalier 3 voire un peu
donc la cia n'avait rentrée qu'est-ce
qu'elle choisit elle choisit de jouer
avec eux 6 6
donc ça c'est une sicilienne je crois
c'est paul scène
peut-être oui il ya des pins parce qu'on
peut on trouver d'autres variantes mais
sur wii c'est un coup assez assez naître
et ça peut transposer dans plusieurs
variantes et or là un coup surprenant
c'est ça ou suivant j'ai être ouais
alors ça c'est l'habituel bruit
sicilienne qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coup raison que j'appelle jusqu'à la
confrontation directe rentrer dans ses
variantes
ouais donc j'ai 3 on va dire c'est donc
l'idée c'est de mettre le fonction qui
tombent du mal à mettre le fonction qui
est au tu penses que c'est pour essayer
d'être plus positionnelle au centre plus
plus lent dans le développement c'est
que kelly dr ce coup oui on un peu tout
ça oui le contrôle du centre il a grandi
et conan h 1 à à 8
voilà cette donation les noirs ont pu
les difficultés à jouer avec à 6b 5-fu
bessette
ouais donc les pions ici noir a6 des 5
est le fruit si c'est plus difficile
parce que dès que les noirs jouent b5
évidemment il ya le fou g2 qui va taper
sur la touraine voilà aussi donc c'est
pour contrer ces variantes à base
d'acide b5 et voilà et au sort les noirs
des grandes lignes en fait oui c'est
l'idée ça t'évite ça évite de jouer trop
théorique et que tu tu as voulu proposer
un combat plus terrain gouard objets 6
alors cavaliers c6 et léger de fougeret
deux là le fameux développement
ça c'est normal même si cette signature
n'est pas tous d'accord
déjà car d'habitude et noir et c'est
même de pousser de jouer avec des cinq
as we de jouer donc le pion central
directement tout de suite pas de suite
mais plus tard il n'a pas pu développer
mais dans ce cas là la vis à vis et donc
avec la d'avancé 7 jouer des 5 devient
plus compliqué voilà parce que s'il est
encore sur sa case de départ
elles protègent mal à pousser d'accord
donc si on combine attendu oui mais bon
je pense m c'est vraiment mauvais j'ai
pas encore dans les cours y bien sûr
mais aussi rock du rock
donc les noirs sorter qu'est-ce que les
pièces à huy
donc là je peux pas poussé le pion aux
cinq ouais parce qu'elle peut jouer qui
avait allégé 4 le pion est alors attaqué
trois fois par les noirs ouais et je ne
pouvais me défendre que deux fois
whistler s'il est si les blancs jouent
objectivement le pion aux leçons qui sur
cette case ici il est déjà attaqué le
pion par le cavalier par la dame et en
plus on peut jouer cavalier g4 avec une
prise de tripes
il sera pris et en plus le talent y sera
bien placé aux 5 parce que vous en place
et on n'est même pas avoir rompu son
pourrait prendre tout de suite oui en
fou mais ça permettrait peut-être ou
blanc de gagner du développement
s'apprêtant sacrifices qu'on est bon en
tout cas c'est dans l'air donc ensuite
donc là il faut protéger le pion ouais
donc je vais 2002 dans leur protocole
plutôt que la tour en fait la tour je
voulais à placer en d1 comme on peut
voir arras ou de la partie voilà
d'accord ça sort ça c'est à savoir c'est
pas évident non c'est naturellement
envie de mettre la tour ou s'ils n'ont
pas poussé le pion en d3 ou sorcière
lecavalier
oui mais dans le dos c'est pas mal parce
qu'effectivement si on joue la tour là
en fait le premier qu'on oublie de se
poser ça peut devenir mais après je mets
où je mets la dame oui ce alors que là
on a déjà un plan moyen terme le dire
mais je sais comment je veux me
développer stade hors jeu mais d'abord
la dame ici
puis après je les trie latour d'accord
donc là j'aurais eu 5 alors qu'ils
bloquent ça ça résout le problème de
dame nature
oui ce sont mes salers une casse faible
en d5
fameuse case deflem ici parce que le
pion 4control cette case et ya plus de
pions noirs qui peuvent attaquer cette
can
et on voit d'autant plus d'importance du
foie en g2 et voilà qui en clonant
protège de classe et donc en
transparence appuyé sur des cinq aussi
nous pensons que c'est nord veulent
jouer des 5 pour se libérer
voilà un autre ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que mon sujet devient
leur très très fort et oui après on peut
imaginer même dans cette position les
noirs desseins
puis on prend alors évidemment ça libère
en plus une colonne contre le roi mais
qu'avaient les prend et tout de suite
dès que ce cavalier bouge
le fou attacked lecavalier en face donc
on pourrait envisager qu'elle allait
prendre quinzaine par exemple pas et
tout de suite gagnant
alors à qui on a gagné un pion puisqu'on
va reprendre le cavalier des cinq et on
a gagné de pyongyang au passage qui en
plus des missions centrales
ça serait chaud donc là maintenant en
plus mis 6 3l plusieurs plans plusieurs
points
ouais mais je pense que ces trois et
c'est pas mal parce que ça contrôler les
cases des 4 et voilà et b 4 6 mai mais
qu'a donc ça veut dire s'amuse elle ce
cavalier
évidemment quand on a joué ses
singuliers ou cinq on se dit pour les
noirs la classe de d4 et peut être formé
mais en fait effectivement à la
différence de la classe des cinq îles
blanc effectivement le pion qui protège
la caisse t4 et voilà donc on voit bien
qu'il faut faire attention au
développement parce que ça impacte tous
les partis donc là surtout que les pions
ne veux pas revenir en arrière et les
pions une fois qu'on les a joués
typiquement c5 et d'essai et 5 c'est
trop tard en plus défendre des cinq très
bien donc des six
alors ça protège et puis ça libère le
food agace prodigieusement peut-être
envie de me ranger 4
donc j'ai joué h3 oui je voulais jouer
je vais penser à tour d un occident on
jouait des quatre de suite c'est comme
tout de suite oui mais si c'est
sacrifier le pion même fizi si parmi
vous des cases peut-être qui affluent g4
qui peut être gênant le fou pourra
peut-être se replacer en g6 et faire un
peu pression si oui bien revenez angers
4 alors soit il au lait blanc
s'affaiblisse un peu sur l'europe sur
toutes les normes par ok donc ils
pourront attaquer avec les pions ils
peuvent toujours choisir le grand roque
peuvent encore choisir le grand raid et
puis en plus si donc si on vous passe au
cou a je crois donc ici on perd mais fou
j'ai clape en dessous des clac qu'on en
vienne nous dire sur fuji 4 en plus on
attaque ici un défenseur de la classe
des quatre oui ce qui fait que ça rend
plus difficile après déclare d'ailleurs
c'est un peu un thème de l'espagnol
voilà c est tout ce que j'avais donc
voilà donc h3 et là je vais fou cette
voie là faut donc là j'hésite encore à
jouer peut-être des quatre de suite
parce que comme on peut le voir dans le
sud a partout quand je joue autour d un
oui on peut continuer à jouer on va voir
on va voir la suite ouais d'accord donc
ici petit rac petit rock fosse est
d'abord un peu cette eau d un
voilà maintenant tournés sur bétirac
retire rock et là on est prêt avec les
blancs puis si on regarde et on a un
pion cavaliers tour pour pousser la
fameuse poussée des cannettes
un petit piège et un petit piège en plus
par attention pour les voilà en faveur
des noirs
il faut quand même être vision donc là
c'était moment je me suis dit c'est
maintenant que jamais donc j'ai joué des
quatre parce que j'avais pas aussi si je
traînais encore qu'elle puisse par
exemple jouer la tour en 1/8 fouet avec
le vis-à-vis de la tour 8 il sort en
vis-à-vis de l'adhan de la dame est donc
toute poussée avec des quatre devenait
oui emblématique puisque ça ouvrait
cette cruelle voilà c'est à dire que sur
des quatre les meneurs peuvent prendre
en 5 et puis comme dit que ce four où
ces deux beaux jours il ya tout rien que
la vallée contre le pion au cap
on pourrait envisager après des dessins
aussi les phoques ça devient vite
pénible donc il faut pas trop traîner
non plus donc maintenant c'est l'heure
des quatre voilà donc on a on a bien
verrouillé en le cas d'une classe
blanche toujours en fin de classe de
centrales toujours un peu faible fait
même carrément faible pour les voilà à
l'envers bonnecaze pour l'éclat du blanc
6 arrive a sauté dessus et c'est les
blancs qui crée une rupture en fait
finalement avec des pièces bien placé
donc ça laisse un bon début pour les
blancs pour l'instant oui je pensais
donc non qu'elle a pris alors elle a
pris duquel pions parce que là il y en a
deux à la prise du pion ses prix avec
ses plans nokia ne touchez pas à
structure de pions pasquet nord avait le
choix de ne pas
c'était pas forcé de prendre de suite je
pensais peut-être moi même un autre
prendre en ces cinq provinces où s'est
ensuite joué avec sur la case des cinq
sets voilà un cavalier est passé par
troyes avec avaya 3 qui avait laissé
quatre qu'avec ces deux avec l'a3 à
cavaler ce cavalier ici aurait pu voilà
si les blés noirs prenez pas ici les
blancs pouvaient prendre ici et ce
cavalier effectivement on aurait pu
bondir ans à 3 puis c'est un peu long
mais ça peut être très dangereux puis en
c2 et c3 et enfin donc contrôler
complètement la casse des semaines sinon
l'autre cavailles en f3 peut passer par
des deux enfin il ya pas mal de
manoeuvres de cavaillé d2 en libérant un
peu le fou aussi parce que nous y
protège mieux 4 des deux c4 et autres
ans et on pourrait même envisager après
à terme il faut qu'un alain dessaigne
que l'autre viana valable s'être essayé
de jouer flou g5 pourrait changer au fou
contre eux cavaliers qui enregistre la
casse dès sa part c'était une idée
d'accord donc lors qu'est ce qui se
passe alors de maintenance et un frein
ici puis en prison alors le désavantage
d'avoir pris avec les noirs c'est que ça
libère la casse ces trois donc notamment
le cas au lit à un seul coup il pourrait
sortir il pourrait sortir en c3 et donc
attaqué il cette fameuse place des 5
mais elle a pris en d4 il s'est créé
pions avec tokyo hélas il y à un piège
si je reprends avec lecavalier
alors on regarde la variante alors oui
elle peut reprendre avec les cavaliers
pour reprendre
hélas si je prends avec la tour le
phocéen est en prise et la piège regardé
le magnifique boom et blanc perdre une
classe et échecs en plus
et puis c'est pas simple oui on a perdu
une pichenette c'est pas une bonne idée
donc c'est un sacrifice transitoire du
pion en d4
d'abord sortir le fouet ou alors c'est
ça ou le cavalier j'ai sorti le cavalier
aura 3 voilà maintenant effectivement vu
que le club était à troyes la tour un
protège des gelées feront maintenant la
possibilité aux points d'écart et aussi
d'attaquer la dame voilà l'idée c'était
de passer par b5 carlier b5 puis de
prendre deux pions des quatre avec soin
le cube soit avec lecavalier en d5 soi
et que cavalier françois autres avec une
belle partie et alors là effectivement
si on à faire sa niche moins évident les
blancs petit avantage de structure
puisque on a deux îlots de pions ici
deux pions et a2 et b21 milo ici avec
eux quatre f2 jettera h3 donc deux îlots
contre 3 pour les noirs avec notamment
un pion isolé en d6 et le flou g2 qui
est très fort qui est très fort j'ai mes
tours qui sont sûrs qu'ils seraient bien
placé je mettrai ma touche à en c1 et
j'ai hâte au rang des acquis avec un
vis-à-vis tour dames je pense que les
pièces seraient actives ouais donc là ce
avait remis alors que font deux morts
parce qu'elles font réagir comment on
clame ajoute dame b 6 d'indécis sort
c'est le problème c'est que le rejoue
une pièce alors qu'elle n'a pas fini son
développement mais là il ya encore un
petit piège c'est que je ne peux pas
jouer cavalier b5
alors qu'à bâle etb c'est maintenant a
été possible parce qu'elle peut prendre
quelques cavaliers le pion à 24 oui
madame protège le cavalier et protège le
pion elle se retrouve surchargé ouais
et donc si je vous reprends un éclat
d'un par exemple ici eh bien on perd le
premier voit là et donc c'est pas bon
pour les poulets pour les blancs parce
qu'on va récupérer le pion ici
le cadre mais on a donné un pion central
passe pas en pourpre prune qui ont des
quatre oui encore un terme avec le four
cette wii cavaliers prendre j'avais le
prince cela on prend lequel le foot
sans doute oui parce que sinon on est
noir à la paire de fouilles inclut en
plus et vous l'avez peut-être là
qu'avait lieu de quelques objets gros
bouchons prend le fou mais à la fin les
noirs sont quand même content les leurs
sont bien je pense que oui parce qu'ils
ont gagné du matériel oui on va
récupérer sur mais peut-être corruption
mais mais au final ils ont égalisé quoi
se brise la structure et est égal à
blake aurait donc d'un v6 va piéger quoi
mais calais alors qu'est ce que tu fais
ce que tu veux cela dit je vais
cavaliers ces deux ici laissez-nous
notamment en attaque des classes mais
sans passer par là le piège est sûr
qu'on n'est pas en attaque on n'est pas
attaqués par adama kamara tours tours 8
donc avec le fameux vis-à-vis que tu
comptes du signal émis au début c'était
comme étant un vis-à-vis de tours dams
étude est que ce flou mais il ya quand
même cavalier sur le qca de la tour
surtout vis-à-vis de la dame donc des
coûts comme des c'est donc là j'ai pris
avec le cavalier avec celui-là robbie ce
qui permet de protéger le pion le pion
aux quatre par le fou d'accord et la
jouer des cinq quand même des singes
envisage à puce des coups comme fois
fuite par exemple
plutôt que des 5 voilà je pense que
lemond choix précis je pense qu'ils sont
un tout petit peu mieux alors oui ces
temps durs qu'on se dit oui c'est
peut-être raison mais c'est calculatoire
ici c'est à dire que l'idée c'est d'y
aller vis-à-vis tour dames
donc si je prends je peux bouger le fou
par exemple lancé cinq pour attaquer
fortement ce qu'elle fait ce qu'elle met
à jouer on va le voir tout de suite donc
oui avoir cette idée ça paraît
surprenant quand même c'est un peu cette
puce et pêchue beaucoup parce qu'on se
retrouve qu'on consent qui semble
impossible parce que des 5 et bien
diront oui oui oui j'ai été surpris
c'est la classe au foot mais tu prends
quand même j'ai pris mon temps peur qua
non j'attaque lequel à lyon prenons le
cas vis tu as pris ta prise donc il n'y
a pas trop le choix il faut la thur que
ces 5 voilà c'est le coup et c'est
l'idée oui donc là l'idée pour l'instant
des noms elle continue la tour attaque
la dame et en plus avec cette manoeuvre
les noirs maintenant avec trois pièces
attaque le cavalier mais en bougeant la
dame on se dit qu'on peut protéger
lecavalier ont déjoué dam des deux parce
que en d3 je crois qu'après m'embêter
avec des coups comme cavalier 2,5 et
gagner du temps mais on pouvait attaquer
la dame d'accord ici on a protégé notre
pièce finalement oui ou à un autre la
variante elle aurait pu peut-être
prendre en d4
c'est parce que la flamme et non la
paperie un des quatre cavaliers prend
fonds prend couperin d'intrants et là il
ya toujours un échec
voilà la pointe tour et choco 1 donc si
on reprend la tour avec la tour
la dame est en crise et oui dame
attention la donne des quatre est en
prison cécile et des petites pointes qui
ont l'air de rien
mais cirque on est obligé quasiment jour
age 2 oui et si base en plus et blanc
jouent faux f1 pour couvrir les chèques
on peut regarder fois sont d'accord les
blancs les noirs aient changé d'âme d'un
grand dam tourteron dame est ensuite
l'axé prend un toit le fou et que ça
fait mal vous prend h3 le fou est sain
et de louer donc on va le récupérer
d'ailleurs les narines gagné une pièce
on peut rien faire contre eux vous
prendre sont tout simplement mal et en
plus la torah est pas près de sortir
puis de cette feinte mais aussi donc il
faut faire attention à ces mariages ou à
acheter donc il faut jouer
alors si vous faut quoi je vois pas là
surtout ray faut jouer on est obligé de
jouer un rôle de protecteur et donc la
tour prend tour à tour contours c'est
oblige à damas reprend vie et le pion à
elle doit être prise d'après guy à donc
c'était cette position qu'il fallait
évaluer
oui je me suis dit bon avec les blancs
jaber de fonds j'ai un pion passé
ouais en d5 oui ça doit pas être si
mauvais que ça d'accord donc c'est que
et je pensais
c'est ce que mon adversaire a dû penser
aussi parce qu'elle n'est pas rentrée
dans cette variante
oui elle essayait de compliquer la
position me de prendre en d4
ici donc finalement au lieu de prendre
des cas étant donné cette variante ou à
la fin finalement en plus d'un pion
central passé oui bien passé avec deux
fous tout à fait
donc on est rentré dans cavaliers 5
voilà et comme tu joues la dame des
dunes quand tu disais tu as dame n'est
pas attaqué oui mais mais sa bouche
la sortie de la douche je pensais pas
avoir tout j'ai un pion de puces mais
j'ai les dames qui est un peu en
bouteille et on va dire d'accord
donc là il elle menace il faut le voir
il ya des thèmes de fourchette alors
quelle fourchette là pour noël ne me
lasse pas mais si par exemple je décide
de bouger le cavalier en v3 oui elle
peut jouer
l'image qu'on peut regarder cette
variante ne sais pas où je voulais un
coup comme je prends h 30 alors un coup
très surprenant fonde prend h3 alors ça
ça donne une pièce oui parce que s'il
est blanc reprennent de fond h 30 je
prends le cavalier avec le fouet un des
quatre plus grands cavaliers et si
d'altran donc il ya un thème une
fourchette fourchette en f3 royal voilà
où donc il faut faire partout en corée
et les états c'est embêtant parce que
j'ai calculé plusieurs variantes
oui et il fallait toujours être vigilant
par exemple si je joue un coup comme
de suite un show detroit alors pareil b3
une autre variante les noirs peuvent
jouer tour des huit qui menacent de
récupérer le clan des cinq toujours un
vis-à-vis en plus tour dames on peut
être embêtant
et si je décide de protéger le pion avec
lecavalier en jouant cavalier 3 toujours
parasol qui avait mis des voilà il ya
sur le thème de fourchette comprend h
trois ans après on prend le défenseur de
la kf3 et à la fin on se reprend encore
une fourche et royal j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi faut quand même il faut pas
craquer non mais ça va vite mais c'est
un peu cette question c'était un peu le
moment clé ouais on crée pas c'est un
fait
c'est là qu'il fallait pas lâcher tu
sens que tu admires position d'attaquant
même ici en pion central en plus sain
tout simplement les normands peu
d'initiatives mais il ya peu
d'initiatives pour laquelle il faut
faire attention non plus easy bon roi h
à 8m de fourchette
terminez prochain finit plus thème de
fourchette c'est à toi qu'est ce que tu
fais là il ya quand même des voix quand
même que les noirs la batterie dame fou
attaque le curé f2 donc faut toujours
rester vigilant
mais pour l'instant le cavalier bloc
voilà le cavalier bloque la case des cas
très très renforcé ce que tu aimerais
faire cb3rob 2 où il est verrouillé le
136 kg fait donc messi a su en jouer
oui là je pensais à elle a joué fou 17
de 7 mais je pensais peut-être un plan
avec h 4 h 5 est pour toi on pourrait
employer 200 alors je n'ai pas je peux
acheter un gage 4 h trail puis hcap pour
essayer d'affaiblir l'euro 1 par exemple
si je joue h4 là maintenant
avec les blancs oui c'est la case g4
libéré ça se libérer donc c'est pas bon
et les noirs taux de menacer tu penses
vraiment h4 oui et si l'un joue g4 alors
j'ai donc les bains jouer un coup comme
je peux ab3 des trains donc si les trois
phases 1 h 4 h l'autre un coup comme g4
pour être rencontrées par cavalier g6 et
on voit que la diagonale noir et akalé
g6 et en a un problème sur cette
diagonale c'est ça surtout que les noirs
encore le fou oui il ya la case f4 qui
va devenir cette case est faible donc
quand le fou la dame viendra ici on peut
contrôler 7,4 en plus surtout envisager
plus tard pourquoi quand même si c'est
compliqué là des batteries d'hommes fou
qui pourrait venir matin oui donc ça
fait peur quoi c'est à dire qu'on a
vraiment affaibli les cases noires grâce
à cette manoeuvre
tu pensais plutôt à ça pour les noirs
oui mais c'est parce qu'elle a fait je
comptais pas jouer j'ai 15 ans je
comptais laisser les pions et c'est
apprendre en g3 reprendre avec l'option
donc après 3h heure comme elle je fous
d'essai laissait aux lieux de cette
manoeuvre qui te semble quand même plus
dynamiques sont d'accord donc qui était
un peu plus rassurés par ce coup qui
donnent une cote côté semble naturel
puisque on développe une pièce mais
c'est vrai que bombay les morts sont
quand même mal ils ont quand même
prendre un point central
donc ils ont peut-être cet éleveur de
décès de tentes est vraiment une contre
attaque quoi oui donc qui rassure un peu
à moscou quand même oui je l'aï rassuré
donc là j'ai joué à b3 je contrôle la
casse ces quatre lecavalier il n'y avait
plus il y appliquer parce qu'il y avait
aussi des idées de câbles ici 4 h la
dame on contrôle cette case c'est
important pourquoi pas la place à 4
aussi bon parce que le fou il tapait sur
la carte meilleur c'est pas très foot
est comme ça avec le cavalier à trois je
peux je cueille 3
on sait quatre cavaliers serez protégé
les sens pour eux aussi plus tard
alliance éclat et surtout un fait sortir
se fout puisque la dame est venue en d2
un peu oblitère un peu sa sortie en baie
de ha long sur contrôler la casse des
cats ça semble très bien et bien aux
rêves des chiens qui est douce en fait
aux amateurs donc c'est plutôt et là tu
te sens quand même on a besoin d'une
position solide avec ça on est foutu
votre vision du copion dessins qu'il ya
toujours des tonnes avec le pion des 5
une fois que j'ai développé pièce là je
me sentais bien mais c'est dire que les
normes peuvent essayer de faire le siège
de ce pion oui et d'ailleurs c'est là
qu'on voit aussi que je fous 17 les
noirs s'enlève les possibilités de jouer
rapidement sur la colonne des puisque le
fou bloc elle peut toujours jouer tour à
des 8 puis remettre le flanc c'est vite
et voilà m ensuite on remarque le fou de
cases blanches et noires n'a pas
beaucoup de cases aussi c'est vrai
peut-être sa meilleure qu'à ça restait 8
6 armand ouais d'accord donc h 3o des
blessures et s'il sait ce qu'elle fait
d'ailleurs sourire d'éminents elle a
joué damas six damas is no qu'elle avait
une petite idée je pense à la carte
elicia donc elle vise à épauler cases
noires à l'écart dans les cases blanches
saclay nord peut jouer sur la case d3
ici mais pour l'instant tout paris à
deux pièces donc là je vais fouler 2 pas
peur il va dans la journée ensoleillée
de ma position je sors les pièces
j'ai été surprise elle a pris l'option
h3 elle a quand même pris le pli loin je
trouve ici alors qu'il ya plus de
videmment il ya plus d'échec parce que
milan quand le roi et là on avait
compris tout à l'heure il y avait des
échelles plus là on voit pas trop
comment parce qu'en plus qu'il ya des
claques protège et il peut être remplacé
soit je crois la prius iii donc là c'est
donc là effectivement là on est devant
quoi cc c'est un c'est une résignation
c'est une combinaison une combinaison
est là elle m'a dit à la france qu'elle
a des ratés
comment va voir donc avec un grand h 3
donc tu prends quand même donc cavalier
e 4 apple qui attaque la dame
voilà c'est ça l'idée 1 voilà il ya des
cases f2 qui a attaqué aussi donc on a
dévié en fait on a des villes défenseurs
et non seulement ce défenseur qu'on
habite à leur île protégée en f3 bon là
c'est moins grave puisqu'on a le
charisme du portage mais il y avait
aussi la case de 4 avec son cavalier qui
attaquent la dame attaqué deux pourquoi
pas j'ai 3 et puis aussi qui peut cette
dame pourrait coulisser par là aussi
plus tard elle peut y avoir des tms il
faut faire attention
d'accord en tout cas mme pillay a un
problème et où la dame parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de la mettre en face de la
tour enfin oui on peut pas la mettre en
la dame n'a pas beaucoup de caves et
voilà l énorme menace aussi selon omv à
kayes problème faisait avec toujours
fourchette avec un roi tour fou ah oui
roy roi toi oui si la dame quitte la
protection de m donc il faut vous n'y
avait pas il n'y a qu'une case en fait
cf cadre oui c'est ça tu joues et d'un
mètre 4 se secoue en fait une halte
quasiment enfin on peut envisager comme
m dames 200 tuellement mais on n'a pas
envie du visage et aux mains d'un f4 ces
attaques le cavalier ça protège sa garde
un contact sur f2 encore dame données
n'étaient pas bons mais a toujours d'un
proche d'eux qu'elle allait prendre dans
prend et à quels alliés problème de et
maintenant voilà et c'est peut-être pour
ça que le midem oui c'était son idée
voilà d'empêcher de la dame
de quoi et contrôler la case d3 comment
avoir ensuite regagné qualité cave et
prend un échec un bouge des c'est la
tour qui saute il ya deux de pièces pour
la tour de pc c'est toujours bien pour
fond c'est toujours bien pour les foyers
blanc sur un plan parce qu'ils ont le
plus haut placé des cinq mais c'est
assez compliqué ça se complique donc
d'un mètre quatre noms cavaliers detroit
pour chaque dame fous et voilà la pointe
donc c'est quand même magnifique c'est
bien joué donc ici cavaliers detroit
on a donné pièces comme donc à tout
moment les blancs peuvent rendre qu'à
l'être attaque la dame attaqué deux et
attaquent aussi le foot on a pas 33 ans
fathi badja obligé de donner la tour
contre les cavaliers
voilà donc dans la combine les noirs
oblige quand même les blancs à rendre au
moins une tour contre auto pièces ce qui
est ce qu'ils changent moins grave que
de 2000 pièces tout court elle même si
c'est quand même malheureux tâche des
blancs oui ça reste un avantage débat
donc là un coup fourré fins et le coût
que mon adversaire n'avait pas vu qui
force les changes des dames
lorsque la dame noire n'est pas le cas
on peut parvenir regarder quand même
pris magnifique la foux et attaque le
flou attaque la dame pointe le cloud
évidemment pêche la dame de venir ici en
c3 s'est pris par le foulée 2 en d2 il
ya la dame f4 donc ya pas le choix lp je
vais encore dan d2 mais là j'ai changé
les dames et je remets
enfant j'ai 2 voilà j'ai une très forte
position prise qu'elle allait prendre
les prendrai là la finale la finale est
positive oui je sais et j'ai deux
piasses pour une tour de plus pour nous
tous voila j'ai affaire de fous j'ai un
pied en place et là c'est le temps qu'il
veut c'est tranquille et oui j'ai
toujours là la jeune je vais fou j'ai
deux regards quand même garder la terre
de fonds donc il faut changer deux pour
éviter de perdre la paire de poussière
tu gardes aussi davantage qu'on sous
estime parfois quand on quand on joue
encore dans les open et pas encore d'un
nationale qu' évidemment les deux fous
ici c'est quand même aussi un atout
extrêmement fort oui
la position est ouverte avec le pion ici
qui est toujours protégé maintenant
parce fou donc il vaut mieux garder la
paire de fou dans quelque chose qu il
faut vraiment apprendre à faire et ne
pas ne pas donner c'est fou comme ça
même si on a un avantage déjà fort les
échanges ne suffisait pas à gagner il
faut garder un maximum de force donc ça
c'était une variante parce qu'elle n'a
pas joué dam des deux oui donc alors on
revient ici sur un peu de poisson
elle a joué j'ai cinq jours encore
surprenante qui t'a surpris aussi
oui mais qui peur parce que j'ai pris
l'option etc reda alors là l'idée donc
bien on sait qu'on attaque la dame et en
cas de prise
tu aurais pu produits pour la dame en
fait non j'ai peur que la dame jusqu en
cas de prise tu avais peut on peut
prendre avec les noirs et ensuite il ya
toujours le thème de fourchette en f2 et
il ya toujours cavalier pour un f2 et
chic qui menace qui permet aux noirs de
gagner du temps et de et affaiblit un
peu le roi blanc oui donc j'ai pris
l'option g5 avec la dame sur échec
cavaliers prend et ensuite j'ai pris le
fou et c'est donc là si on fait le total
fin c'est le bilan le bilan de cette
combinaison je me retrouve avec deux
pièces contre une tour de pièces est un
pion même un pur passé en d5 une
structure de pions qui est bonne
qui est bonne puisque on a deux îlots
bien deux options qui sont quand même
lié ici alors que même les noirs encore
2 0 mais avait des pions ici les délits
délié donc face à fait 3e ou de coûts et
donc du coup même c'est un terme
structure de pioncer mieux que bien
c'est un pion plus central et en plus
même les îles option mois donc et deux
pièces pour contre une tour c'est plus
fort encore faut-il savoir les manier
parce que oui parfois on a deux pièces
contre le tour on en arrive pas on
n'arrive pas à gagner comme oui ce qui
est important c'est de garder une bonne
cohésion entre les pièces ces deux-là
leur force c'est qu'elles se protègent
les uns les autres et on commence à voir
des thèmes parce qu'elle vient on se
fout là ils contrôlent les cases noires
proche du roi
les cavaliers aux saintes qui peuvent
rebondir et quand on un jour d' attaque
comme toi parce que tu es une chose d'
attaque très bonnes joueuses de de fond
de court tu tu vois pas été désigné
déchets réclament tous voila c'est tout
sauf les yeux brillent à ce moment là en
ce moment là j'ai d'ailleurs depuis le
début que j'ai joués euros à charge
étaient pas très bien le temps oui donc
savait que sa combinaison
mais oui elle n'était pas très bonne
mamie dans une situation de stress parce
que je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps pour
tout calculé voilà donc c'est là aussi
tout est un facteur important dans cette
partie des aspects psychologiques qu'on
a vu le avantages que tu as pris au
début tu aimes bien manoeuvré derrière
bon des tentatives calculatoire que tu a
réfuté finalement mê thuôt te retrouve
quand même effectivement avec un déficit
fort en temps parce que comme une belle
avance je crois je continue à rester
calmes pour jouer 15 coups voyez c'est
ça
déjà fait beaucoup oui ça fait beaucoup
mais il ya trente secondes par coup oui
un rajout des trains seulement par coup
et comme lassitude à la position est
assez stable est bonne pour les blancs
donc là j'ai pris mon temps pour pour
concrétiser mon avantage donc à l'ordre
peu après tout grand des trois donc il
me semble qu'elle a joué cavalier
leucate que le plâtre revient le nas
attention l'hebdo échec donc jeu avec
mouvement 3g je protège le piège de 10
ans g2 en plus qu'on est vite devenir
évidemment j'ai un puisque ans j'ai
donné plus proche du centre c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux il y avait aussi des
thèmes pas enfoui pas jouer des coups
comme camaïeu 3 parce qu'il ya des
thèmes comme cavaillé projet 3 wii de la
mg3 avec la tour qui prend le cavalier
derrière qui vaut mieux 30g de bien
protéger ses petits emballages protéger
ce qu'on naturel par m je me sois
possibilité de faire passer ma tour en
achat qui pourrait toujours
et voilà donc là c'est l'idée qu'on
commence à voir ce fou qui tape sur un
peu désuni
dès qu'un lit derrière en deuxième foot
à coucy h7 on se dit qu'on n'est pas
revenu protège des cavaliers 6 qui
attaquent les pions des cinq un cavalier
prévalu 3 qui protège tout tient
tranquille ou rappeler que maintenant
que le faut et en b2b sur le cac les d4
ici dans mon cocon contrôle des cinq
tours à des huit sans doute non c'est
pas ça
j'aime bien oui document les tourrades
évite internet pour la retourner vite
voilà donc la foux c4 voilà comme j'ai
dit j'étais oui c'est être un hymne
manqué du temps a pas eu de consigne en
a pas prendre de risque on a protégé
sûrement qu'il y avait une manière de
gagner
willow rien à gagner beaucoup plus
rapide c'est difficile à calculer leur
efficient on se dit des coups comme ça
paraît non ça a l'air fort parce que oui
j'attaque et on se dit qu'à balayer 5
attention le fou attaque ce fou dont on
a toujours un oeil sur 7
et puis sur un échec lors on est obligé
de venir en fuite mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut tout calculer pour savoir si
vraiment ça vaut le plan des scènes
parce que on donne une chance en train
donc qu'elle fout des scènes c'est fou
ces quatre c'est quand même un coup
disons solide coin c'est difficile pour
les noirs mais on peut avoir peur de
l'a6b cinq ici pour essayer de
déstabiliser ce cas là je vais pas tout
de suite donc ici donc après nos cages
des cavaliers 17
mais cette ruelle d'accord donc là
cavalier ds5
on arrive avec les pièces alors
attention le fou contre le roi le
cavalier qui visent des cases dangereuse
aussi la tour qui peut venir en h1 et
effacée par la 4e par exemple en
l'avenir en 1 h 4 pour faire un échec g4
que matheux rapide simple et les
vraiment beaucoup
il sent que ça va mater vite celui-ci se
passe ça n'a comme tu l'as dit elle a
joué à six
alors voilà a6 avant l'idée d'assisses
c'est que mais sur l'idée c'est
déstabiliser le fou ces quatre pour
attaquer des 5
mais comment avouer qu'elles
occasionnent des sept îles en attaque
pas tout de suite des scènes tout cet
été quand même très lent que je vais
cavaillé g4 voit la menace matin oui
mais là c'est matt alors là ça manas
maths on ne compare alors imaginons que
les noirs jouent bc messin c'est parce
qu'elle a fait
mais là ils ont fourré dans ce cas là
cavalier h suivant le roi et forcé
d'alors écrite alors comme le fou qu'on
regarde et contrôle toutes les
diagonales ni obligé maintenant de venir
en afrique et comme on contrôle les deux
cases ici hop
magnifique je suis pas comme ils
s'appellent du matin il décolle là c'est
joli c'est trois pièces qui formate
quand un très bon pied ce mineur c'est
toujours très intelligent auquel est
forcé de jouer frais fuite pour
contrôler la casa chif donc elle joue
beaucoup défensif forcé ou les fuites
jeu j'empêche l'échec
disons le match parce que jean pêche pas
l'échec puisque vous préférez chez qui
prend encore échec lui le roi s'échappe
après réfute voilà je fais cavaliers six
échecs travail et si ce temps qu'il
pourrait changer finalement cela alors
là on se dit qu'au coût comme coûtera
cher avait l'air fort parce que oui
c'est sûrement très fin on peut venir un
jeune pour mélanger 5 ou 6 ou voir un g4
je pense que sinon passez par après kf
si je pensais être passé par castrés
les quatre allongé 4 d un des cloîtres
aussi mais là cette position est déjà
gagnante pour les blancs donc je me suis
dit on va jouer
moi je vous tranquille oui il me restait
toujours une limite à la pendue donc ça
aussi bonnes fins de tenir compte des
lois ils sont ou pas on peut pas tout
calcul est donc il faut pas non plus
jouer des matches où on sacrifie trop de
matériel et bien avoir un autre enfant
mais je me suis trompé j'ai le temps de
temporiser donc ici qu'à l'épreuve qui
est prend fou prend qui attaquent la
truffe voilà qu'ils gagnent du temps
notamment la pendule puisque la tour est
attaqué on peut pas venir un des six
pour attaquer le fou puisque le
cavaliere cinq ou six attaques
donc ya pas trop le choix elle est allée
en 17 ans vient d'estimer la part
toujours contrôler la case des six donc
je vais à 4 parce qu'ils voient la halle
4 et jouer des flics donc la menace b5
si des scènes prises prise vous prend et
végétales est en finale puisque on
attaque les deux tours par l'oph ou et
effectivement ça c'est pas bon puisque
les blancs vont récupérer la qualité et
c'est avec une pièce depuis ces pièces
net de peluches exception de puces ça
finit par faire très très cher mais
c'est déjà cher donc je vais tout retour
des 8 pour menacer de pousser 8 pour
protéger la poussée des 5
regardez quand même des coups quand même
intéressant surtout qu'après si par
exemple je ne fais pas attention est
tombé 5
oui mais ça tu apprends qu on prend le
flou de bougé depuis on est 5 est en
prise et l attaque et le câble est
attaqué après la prise donc il faut
faire avec faut trouver une solution kg
poussé le coeur a5 à magnifique
alors ça c'est une défense et qui est
joli et bien on ne pense pas pas
toujours puisque ça empêche des scènes à
cause de la fameuse tout dix ans
et on prend en passant et on a plus de
problème ce fou est définitivement
protégé par un pion b3 qui viennent
délogeables donc les magnifiques elle a
quand même joué b500 ordre a activé sa
tour noms communs dit la prise en
passant prise en face à la fameuse
pourtant pour prendre et donc là j'ai
simplement qu'on soit une évolution en
fout des quatre s'agit pas de me prendre
le pion à six parce qu'il ya toujours
les thèmes de à la fin oui prise en
dessin oui parce que tu aurais pu faire
tout reprend assez sain oui parce que le
bateau aussi contrôler la 6e donc
évidemment la tour ne peut pas prendre
le fou et tout reprend foutra le pion
des cinq étant prises et il faut pas le
lâcher se plaint du coût des quatre
attaques la tour sans perdre de temps
on est attaqué mais on renvoie la balle
c'est à dire que l'on peut pas non plus
perdre du temps à contre-attaquer mais
auquel je vais toucher 6 mai pendant le
choix soir entre baie vitrée
c'est que les pièces c'est là on voit la
force des deux des pièces longues heures
contre la tour oui ces contrôles et
normand de territoire beaucoup plus
dotés de casques anti coup de casque je
te casse pour la tour seules elles
peuvent se protéger elle sera contre le
plus grand de l'échiquier ouais et donc
douleur forte
d'où l'intérêt d'en avoir deux plutôt
qu'une
voilà tout à fait super g a perdu fou la
position est ouvert c'est effectivement
agréable et une position qui déjà et est
très très certainement arch
nantes donc là je suis passé tout le
temps je voulais aller en 8 avec des
terres donc tu laisses tomber la
pression sur a6 que tu aurais pu aussi
jouer un coup comme cavaillon 3 pour
essayer de faire le siège des assises
mais tu préfère jouer à petit finalement
parce qu'il ya le roi qui est faible et
où il ya plus de tours qui protège la
huitième rang j'ai pour les noyades et m
qui se dessine le roi est toujours
utilisé est toujours faible et peut-être
des thèmes de maths du pouvoir bon et
bien sûr tout âge active la tour mais
encore plus en plus à une menace de
devenir donc la cua a ajouté roger
quatre tours j'ai quatre attaques
petites attaques sur des cats mais il
est protégé par f5 jouer et je vais tout
objet sacré voilà tour g5 qui attaquent
le cavalier d'abord le cavalier c'est
mieux je veux qu'à l'aller h4 tu peux
aussi après jouer un coup comme f4 louis
latour angers 5 n'est pas très bien
placé on voit qu'elle a très peu de
cases
donc il y avait toujours des thèmes avec
sa menace commune au spot presque de
gagner je pense qu'à la tour d'être
perdue avait perdu parce que ceux restés
à trouve à la tourelle peut pas les f-5
la cause du cavalier dans le scène par
le fou en dessin vidant ses protégés
pont du reste la classe astres qui reste
h scène mais elle va se faire harceler
par l'europe peut-être par exemple
laurent pourrait venir étrangers 4 oui
il ya énormément de talent énormément de
thèmes donc c'est très dangereux et donc
on approche ou presque la du de la fin
cafouillage quatre fous 7e cette petite
aime quand même il se dit bon j'attaque
le cavalier un peu par transparente il
est aussi un clouage le piège est très
court bouillon g3 qui protège le
cavalier notre nature des petites faut
être vigilant il faut être très vigilant
face à sylvie colas parce que posent des
pièges jusqu'au bout et a pesé pierre et
je vais très bien petit mot nasa serait
de jouer par ème tour j'ai quatre
attaquants fou et attaque le cavalier et
le cav a été taclé par l'autre fou avec
un clouage avec le pion j'ai trop flou
et donc ça peut être effectivement et en
plus un temps fou c'est en empêche
pour évidemment oui en tout huit donc la
jouer cavalier f3 qui attaquent la tour
on apprend que tout le monde voit donc
la tour n'a pas beaucoup de casse si la
tour vent je suis saoul ou angers kg
sicilienne fourchette
voilà comment j'ai quatre singles à
venger de l'affront n'a pas peur de la
plus du fou parce que tu es aux lieux
saints tout reprend fouet qu'elle valait
pro tour et on a une pièce de fusent
toujours et toujours pièce de plus donc
il ya beaucoup de gaz a joué tout
racheter et la cavalière caillou 5 qui
attaquent la tout cas le attaque 17 ans
dé comme les piles ce cavalier sait
recycler les terres et 5 tac tac tac up
se retrouvent au centre
voilà donc par exemple tour des huit il
ya cavaillé c6 les pochettes turfoo
torfou et latour rajoute ce qui fait
qu'on en gagnera la niña soin tout à
fait voilà sur un tout comme tours
ces sept pour ces sept possibles il y a
encore cavaliers c6 malgré tout puisque
évidemment encore une fois le fou de
t'attaquer way et com et sur un coup
comme roy et fuites qui protège on prend
le font avec lecavalier et surtout
reprend il ya un fossé 5 et la tour et
couvrira c'est le relais voilà quand
j'ai joué cavalier 5 sylvia et voilà
donc beaucoup trop fort il n'y a pas de
coups mais on arrivait aux 45 ou
contrainte de temps allait passer oui ok
c'est en fait à l'heure du moment que tu
avais plus davantage centrale à
continuer à jouer du fait du déficit de
temps oui et puis avait toujours des
petites des titres externe acquis apm
deux tours donc content de cette
première partie alors contente oui quand
soulagement c'est un bon début ouais
alors si c'est pas ton premier national
était déjà quelques-uns oui mon premier
national était en 2005
voilà et ensuite j'ai joué quelques
nationale puis après j'ai mes études
j'avais puisse difficulté oui des études
d'ailleurs longue parce que tu le
médecin c'est soit tu fais des études de
médecine
oui je les ai finalement je suis pas
encore médecin j'ai encore quelques
années d'études mais là je vais pas sans
6ème année comme une autre joueuse
d'ailleurs à huy pauline richard qui
elle aussi ciel et déjà elle fait son
internat déjà un mois donc la médecine
c'est à ce taux d'échec
ça c'est curieux d'accord donc comment
tu vois ce national c'est quoi ton
ambition cette année tube tu espères à
faire quoi
résultat est-ce que tu as eu un peu de
ton ne pas sauter un objectif oui bien
sûr comme toute personne qui participe à
ces nationale
pour gagner gagner carrément tu viens si
je le titre wells sinon je serais pas de
la compétition oui mais tu pourrais vite
tu pourrais te dire je vise le podium où
j'essaie de béziers c'est de faire plus
de la moitié des points où je sais pas
enfin pas si on faisait podium pourquoi
ne pas viser tiennent bon votre bien
être bien parce que bien sûr que c'est
ambitieux mais c'est ma philosophie
d'abord vous à la plus haute marche et
après son résultat s'adapte naples est
sûr visé on va d'abord donc c'est tout
le plus ok c'est comme ça qu'on puisse
avoir d'accord tu vises d'avoir le plus
haut puis après en fonction des
circonstances du tas d'amis passer à
trépas partie après partie on s'adapte
on adapte ses objectifs lahoud est mené
un tournant on ne va pas viser le milieu
du tableau
on pourra y en a un regard du 1er au 6
dorfman par exemple d'armée nationale
yves launay il fait beau toute nue il
visait pas forcément le titre
sinon il leur prix que le coup d'arrêt
physique il n'en prenez pas tendre ça
donc il cherchait surtout à faire un bon
tour n'en a pas forcément à faire un
résultat
c'est vrai donc on est sa dépendance est
vrai il ya des stratégies différentes
selon les joueurs
d'accord mais ok d'accord on sait qu'on
a pas chez aviso plus haut on essaie des
renforts a le meilleur résultat
enfin dernier lot
mais si on perd ensemble pour nos
pharmacies c'était un objectif qui va
paraître impossible mais enfin pourquoi
la compétition c'est sa c6 est d'accord
mais par rapport aux autres
compétitrices mousser sa compétitrice du
national elias jaua ce qu'ils sont très
fortes
mais ce que tu les a déjà battus tout il
y en a peu besoin de mon match mais j'ai
joué contre certaines jésus dit abattu
mondiale battue d'accord mais papa tout
moi-même y en a quelques-unes quelques
contres qui pour l'instant le résultat
positif ce n'est pas encore là on est
d'accord c'est des nuls oui oui des
nuits
donc si tu gagnes quand on sait que tu
as déjà battu déjà par exemple que tu
fais que des nulle part ailleurs
tu peut même viser le titre parce que
oui enfin bon comme c'est possible
donc tout est ouvert c'est possible mais
merci natacha persie auteur non merci
pour cette 12 heures suivie à pour cette
première émission tv spéciale saint
quentin 2015 c'était avec natacha
benmesbah après cette première ronde
très jolie une belle partie contre 6 kg
à colas qui est quand même pas la
première joueuse devenu membre de
l'équipe de france merci à toi natacha
merci à vous et je vous dis donc à
bientôt pour notre émission qui connaît
la tv